there's microprocessors practically
anywhere and
most of them are hidden most of the
people don't even know
and
[Music]
thank you so much for joining on 20
minute leaders
thank you thanks so it's good to be here
so we're going to talk about metal
today right bare metal yeah bare metal
you know as a young entrepreneur going
through
stanford here in palo alto we see all
the sexy things on the news and all
these new and shiny devices
and and really really cool things but
sometimes i think we forget to look back
and really the
you know the the core of what's
happening in the core of technology
which you've been dealing with for quite
quite some time now
as you know in vp engineering positions
is cto positions
let's talk about metal but first giddy
tell me a little bit about where you
come from
okay so i've been a cpu architect pretty
much my whole career i've
uh started way way back
uh in israel and was having the
computer architecture team at national
semiconductor
moved to the us with national worked for
a
good number of years for another cpu
company called mips technologies
and until this morning i was working at
a semiconductor company called
advesto which today was acquired by
different
semiconductor companies
thank you very much yeah we're all happy
about you're saying it's so
so casually really yeah thank you
how many how many acquisitions of this
so now have you been a part of
oh a good number of acquisitions there's
a lot of stuff that's happening in the
semiconductor business now it's not as
visible as the
software business or the apps business
but a lot of
uh things are happening i was admitting
it was acquired
i was uh consulting a number of uh
startups that were a bunch of them were
acquired and now this company that i'm
in was uh the deal was closed this
morning
unbelievable get on why is this not in
the news
why are i mean this is obviously in the
news you just have to to look a little
bit deeper than
you know another autonomous vehicle
company being acquired
but why is bare metal not in the
headlines
well first you just don't read the
correct uh you know
sources of media right that's 100 true
um well uh it's uh it's not as sexy as
uh
as a software uh it takes us much longer
to
get to an exit in this business uh
this business requires significantly
higher investments
so two people in their garage
cannot really get a company
to an exit within a couple of years that
doesn't happen
attesto which is the company that i was
part of has been around for 13 years
before it was acquired about
eight nine years before it got uh it
went public
wow so it takes much much longer
and the problem is we're building
semiconductor devices you call it bare
metal but uh what we're doing is
designing semiconductor chips that are
pretty much the the baseline for pretty
much all the software that's been
used in the world and we have to do a
lot of things
uh to make this happen and it just takes
time and money okay so you know
let's dumb it down for me because i know
nothing about this what
is what what is the semiconductor
business what are these technologies
what are you what are you building on a
day-by-day basis
so it depends different companies are
building different things you know
everybody knows about the intel which is
building you know the cpus that are
driving the the pcs and now apple is
going to be building their own cpu
that's going to drive the new mac
machines uh so these are the things that
are typically much more in the news then
there's another tier of companies that
are building
products that go into cell phones so a
lot of people know about
qualcomm and other such providers
but then you go deeper and for example
the business that we're part of which is
uh
the industrial iot uh
these these devices are done by a whole
bunch of
smaller companies and uh
most of them you just don't have a clue
that these devices are sitting within
your uh
your printer or your uh you know
food processor so we're literally
talking about the chips
the chips that are in almost everything
that we see in our day today right now
exactly and many of them include cpus
inside so
a lot of them at the end of the day are
running softer so there's
a lot of uh design that goes into
these systems first building the chip
then building the software around it so
even the software people that are
building the software that goes into
that are not engineers nobody knows
about them but that's what
actually is driving your car and that's
what driving pretty much
every one of these devices that you know
you're
buying at amazon right no that's that's
just incredible and
you know take me back a few years
because you've been in this space for
quite some time and you know i grew up
into a world that
iot internet of things devices are
prevalent and almost everything i touch
has a has a brain of its own but
i think when you started in this
industry it wasn't like this right
no no no no no uh when you know i've
been in this business about 30 years and
uh you know even at that time computers
were
relatively scarce you know there was a
typically a car had
one processor that was controlling the
the engine and that was it today a car
will have
you know hands and tons of
microprocessors that are doing
everything from rolling the windows down
all the way to
showing you the way uh you know even a
cell phone has a number of
microprocessors inside uh
dealing with different functionalities
so there's microprocessors practically
anywhere
and most of them are hidden most of the
people don't even know and and this
uh what the internet of thing is doing
today is what used to be called in the
past embedded systems which were
you know systems where the software was
deep inside nobody knew that about this
software it was just done by whoever
built this system but there was no way
to update or upgrade it
uh now with uh the internet of things
pretty much all these pieces are capable
of being upgraded and updated
over time which makes it beautiful it
allows you to add features
later in time tesla is made a whole
business of
upgrading your car pretty much after you
actually
bought it which is something that was
unheard of in in the car industry before
incredible so what is there to come
because it seems that now
you know everything everything is
already connected and everything is
pretty much communicating with itself so
what what are you know the big
milestones that we can foresee
in the next few decades big thing that's
happening right now is actually taking
ai
and driving it all the way to the edge
of the network so
your uh you know the camera in your uh
in in your door uh will actually be able
to
figure out whether it's your somebody
else so and
a whole bunch of other applications
where the
knowledge to know how the processing
power
whether it's standard processing power
or even ai
will all be at the end of the network
the edge of the network without the need
to go back to the servers
and make decisions and do that requires
that
first for you to be connected and second
there's latency you don't want
uh stuff to go up to the network and you
don't really want
amazon to actually take all the uh
words that are being said within your
living room and send them up to their
server
you want you want to get the service but
you want it to be done
locally without amazon actually getting
that information and storing it on their
server so
a lot of this in intelligence coming
down
right to the edge of the network will
make a big change in the way
uh these devices are operating right so
and it sounds to me that
there are some hidden difficulties or
hidden challenges that
you know a software engineer like myself
may not even under
realize because you know i could be
developing artificial intelligence
models
pretty easily either using you know auto
ml by google or just tensorflow
with python or pytorch but it sounds
like what you're saying is that the
challenges of of running these
models on device on the camera that's on
the door
is not just the software there's a lot
of you know the the processing power and
the memory
those are all challenges that we're
still facing today right i can't afford
to put a
you know a server farm in my house so
you have to figure we have to figure out
ways to make these algorithms more
efficient to make the hardware more
efficient so it would be able to run it
in many cases you need to be running it
with a limited amount of energy
right for example the battery-operated
devices so there's a lot of innovation
that's going on right now
into building devices that are smarter
and capable of doing these smart things
at the edge with the limitations of cost
power
and um pretty much everything else that
uh that is uh what you expect
at the end of the day to have in your uh
you know
right next to your front door definitely
so and and your
the things that you're building are they
are are these the challenges that you're
working on
making these things possible yeah we are
working on uh we're working on
ai at the edge we're also working on
security
at the edge so all these devices need to
be secured
and uh you really want to make sure that
nobody manages to
penetrate in your house into your bank
account through your uh you know
through your uh connected fan right so
there's a lot of work that's being done
in these areas as well
yeah i believe that it was a somebody
shared with me a paper from the technion
of a couple of people who managed to to
actually hack
a fan a ceiling fan and get some
personal data about people through that
right right right yeah pretty
fascinating so you know
what excites you about this i mean this
does sound exciting now that you're
explaining
what it what it allows but at the end
you know you're not working on the
camera
of ring and you're not working on the
ceiling fan you're working on on the
technologies that
then companies can use to make their iot
right
right but what what's happening is that
the
engineering uh uh companies that are
building the end product
uh are becoming trying to become leaner
and leaner and what happens is that the
semiconductor vendors that are
offering devices to these applications
are providing significantly more
software
and more of the application within
the device within their offering if you
look today
at the tv for example the chip that's
actually controlling the tv
uh comes from a vendor that provides not
just the chip but the operating system
and
okay a lot of the software at the end of
the day uh
the various oems uh you know the main
difference between their devices would
be just the brand name
on that pops up when you turn on the tv
uh could easily be that ninety percent
of the software is the same
software that was built or provided by
the semiconductor vendors so
semiconductor vendors are actually
becoming much more of a vertically
integrated
suppliers of a lot of the software and a
lot of the solution
we're providing these the devices we're
providing the software
we're providing even boards that include
all the
pieces together and then in many cases
oems in china and
in taiwan would just take these designs
and
pretty much take them to production
fascinating and you know
are there you know demographic shifts
that you're seeing in the industry in
terms of
you know young people coming into it
because i'm just thinking about my
experience at stanford
it's much sexier to go into software and
just to use python to write these
you know machine learning code and
honestly most of the companies that are
coming to hire on campus that's what
they're looking for
i don't remember a single company that
came that had a standout and said come
work with us in the semiconductor
industry
so what's happening with that well uh
it's
our industry is actually becoming older
you go and visit the offices and you'll
see people that are
you know slightly older than the people
that uh you would see at uh
typical uh google uh um you know site
right
um yeah that's true although we're still
uh getting a lot of young engineers uh
there is a shift
of engineering uh from the us
into other places where people value
the semiconductor business more so
you'll see tons of
startups in in china really uh you'll
still see
a bunch of startups coming up in israel
oh yeah
uh by the way why why is why why was
israel a hub or
still a hub for this why is that
that's a good story uh has to do with uh
with multiple uh different things but
one of them was
intel intel uh came to israel in 1974
and started the design center and then
within a few years engineers from
intel's
start moving to to other companies they
thought they'd have
better opportunities with still with
american companies so
motorola and national conductors father
design centers
but then in the late 80s people started
realizing that there's
opportunities with startups and money
came in a lot of people got to a
pretty much a glass ceiling in terms of
uh as a subsidiary of a big american
company couldn't get
any further so what happened was that uh
and and money was relatively abundant
and
so startup started and
i can tell you that in the early 2000s
uh
israel was but probably more startups
than
practically any place in the world maybe
with the exception of
silicon valley um even now i think there
are
more semiconductor startups in israel
than practically anywhere
in the world it's not the same numbers
as there were in the early 2000s
but it's still a huge number so it's not
that it was you know more common just to
go to the teflon and study
the space it was more so that the
industry by chance
came to israel in 1974 people saw the
opportunity
and it got it got everybody excited
yeah and it was an exciting uh business
uh
think about it at that time the other
businesses were mostly you know built uh
boxes for you know elta or elbit yeah
and uh
so people uh some of the top people
in the industry uh or actually the top
students out of the technion went to
to work for for intel national and
motorola
at the time i remember you know i joined
a little bit later than that much later
than that about
15 years later but at the time for
every job at national we had about 100
people that were applying
wow we definitely rejected people that
were extremely good
some of them are ceos of companies that
exited with millions and millions of
dollars and we told them no you're not
fit for uh working for us we just
could just pick whoever we wanted to to
work at the company
unbelievable and is there now is there a
scarcity
and and good engineers in the
semiconductor space
i think there's always been scarcity in
terms of uh
good engineers good engineers are not
growing on trees and
it's always been a challenge and then
now
there's definitely a bigger challenge
due to the fact that there's
a lot of people that are going to uh
other businesses
and i don't think that the universities
are generating enough engineers neither
in the u.s nor in israel
right no it's and and it's interesting
to hear that there's it seems that
there's there is a shift
to asia for a lot of these for a lot of
these businesses
as opportunities are rising and i'm
really curious to know about leadership
in the semiconductor space
i talked to quite a few uh you know
executives and leadership positions in
the software space where i'm at
what what is it like leading technology
and leading teams
in the semiconductor space from your
experience is that different than in the
software space or
are these you know sort of two similar
animals
i think that pretty similar animals
there's
obviously a little bit of a difference
in terms of what you need to achieve
right also the length of time that it
takes to come to production right i mean
it takes years versus months there's
also the risk software doesn't have to
be perfect
when it comes out of yeah factory you
can update it and upgrade it
and uh you know people invented this
model of
let my customer debug my code uh
you can't do that with semiconductor
with semiconductor you take
chip out meaning you take it to
production and then if you have a bug it
will take you about six months to fix
that box so
and the cost of fixing that bug could be
hundreds of thousands or could be
millions of dollars so
you can't really afford to to have bugs
um
so the result is that the complexity of
semiconductor devices
is not as big as a complexity of a very
of a big
uh software system where you know
there's
hundreds of people working on the same
project
i think the biggest projects are you
know intel's microprocessors probably
you know one or two thousand people wow
on a program
most programs are much much smaller with
you know
tens or hundreds of people uh but uh
and and then but so i think at the end
of the day
software systems could be significantly
more complex and more
uh difficult to manage
however they manage it to just operate
not be
bug-free where in the semiconductor
business you have to
uh figure out a way to to make it
bug-free and
the result was a lot of tools that were
designed to
uh help uh the engineers actually
figure out ways to to clean the bugs you
know bugs are always
inherent you just need to figure out a
way to get most or all of them out of
the
design before you you roll it out it's i
mean it sounds pretty scary
you've got to experience quite a few
roll outs and deployments of these chips
i mean you fin you deploy them and
you're like okay we did it like
we did our thing i guess we're working
on the next thing and let's just hope
that we don't wake up and see an article
that says that there's a huge bug in one
of our chips
yep yep well you've seen what happened
to intel with some of these
security bugs you know yeah this is a
disaster you know the the
the number of chips that are deployed
and the time that it was found which was
in
some cases years after the chiefs were
right the market
and now what do you do about it so in
many cases you find some workarounds
some of them are
uh you know reducing the performance of
the device and some of them
[Music]
are not completely full uh full growth
and and you have to live with it
i think i recall that there was an
interesting case study from one of my
business school classes of
a time when a chip it was found that it
made it once
every million calculations it had a
miscalculation error right
and and it was a huge deal of how does
the company you know do they
do they collect all the chips back but
you can't because they're already in all
the computers and
and it was fascinating right right right
right yeah it's a huge huge problem and
uh there's tons of money that's involved
in that both for the
semiconductor vendor that's building the
chip and for the oem that sells it
at the end of the day not an easy
problem to deal with
i think it takes a lot of courage to go
and sell something to millions of people
and
and hope that nobody finds anything
wrong hey it's
much easier than being uh you know uh a
structural engineer that's responsible
for
bridge that falls or a doctor that
is actually doing surgeries on the
spectrum it's it's not that bad
i love it okay get on right before we
leave i want to thank you again for the
time that you're giving this and we
didn't even talk about
you know i'm very curious you're also
part of j ventures
as a limited partner there so you're
also you know active with early stage
startups
and and you're active also in helping
you due diligence and and i love that
you're also you're balancing
these two worlds very technological yet
also on the investment side but before
we leave
i have to ask three words that you would
use to describe yourself
okay so i would say
innovative problem solver that's
probably the
easiest way to describe it innovative
problem solver i love it it's all about
solving problems in the end isn't it
yeah i love it you don't thank you very
much
and congratulations on the acquisition
from today morning
yeah amazing amazing all right take care
bye bye bye